expérimentation minimaliste dans le hall
pour les étudiants de première année
situé dans l'ancienne chocolaterie
poulain l'école du paysage de blois
initié par jacques lang forme depuis
vingt ans des ingénieurs paysagistes
donc le fil par être symbolisé la
longueur du rhône quand bal de la
formation se déroule sur cinq ans et
apporte de nombreuses disciplines jouant
l'alternance entre théorie et pratique
lolita paysagiste et maître de
conférences en 5 ce métier en
perpétuelle évolution et au champ
d'activité très large
ça va être des personnes qui vont
travailler sur l'espace à différentes
échelles d'espacé donc ça peut être une
très petite échelle une jardin par
exemple une place urbaine ça peut être
aussi réfléchir à l'avenir d'une ville
donc à l'évolution d'un quartier à la
transformation d'une friche d'un nouveau
quartier la création d'un nouveau
quartier puis ça peut être réfléchir à
des grandes échelles parfois des
échelles qu'on nomme prospective aussi
c'est à dire sur un temps long voilà ça
va être des futurs acteurs de
l'aménagement du territoire donc avec
cette compétence paysage
on va prendre ce métier il ya besoin de
temps il ya besoin de connaissances qui
sont plutôt donné pendant les deux
premières années donc ça va être des
connaissances techniques des
connaissances scientifiques
ça va être aussi des expérimentations
artistiques pour apprendre en fait à
monter un projet à définir une méthode à
concrétiser une expérience
l'histoire géologie biologie botanique
dessin mais aussi sciences humaines et
sociales communication et management
autant de matières nécessaires à la
conception et à la réalisation d'un
projet paysager pour permettre aux
étudiants de mieux cerner les réalités
du métier
l'école travaillent sur des commandes
réel émanant de collectivités du cabinet
d'architectes de paysagistes par rapport
à au travail que tu as déjà fait au
niveau de la mise en place de ton projet
tu en es où aux antilles du coup j'ai à
disposition de l'égalité lolita comme
d'autres enseignants accompagnés
individuellement les étudiants de 5e
année sur leur travail de fin d'étude
auquel il consacre six mois l'objectif
est de concevoir un projet de le mettre
en oeuvre et de le communiquer au
travers d'une publication de plans
d'image ou de maquettes
c'est une pédagogie qui à la fois
développe beaucoup voilà la personnalité
l'étudiant essaye de donner à l'étudiant
des outils qui va pouvoir utiliser qui
sont les siens en fait tout simplement
et puis en même temps une bonne
connaissance d'une solide connaissance
des autres compétences afin que ensuite
on puisse travailler c'est vraiment
l'importance de cette école c'est qu'on
ait des mais bon généraliste des
généralistes engagé mais qui permettent
du coup de travailler avec d'autres
équipes d'autres compétences
il essaie de conserver l'idée que le
travail du paysage c'est un travail de
l'espace et des méthodes d'analysé
projet et on les retrouve à toutes les
échelles que ce soit un petit jardin de
quelques dizaines de mètres carrés des
territoires de plusieurs dizaines de
kilomètres carrés c'est avant tout la
méthode la façon de comprendre l'espace
qui tu fais le travail de prise et
paysagiste il faut de la curiosité
pointe d'humilité certainement aimé
l'humain et ils s'intéressaient
intéresse l avenir
la liberté de pouvoir répondre de
répondre à des demandes en faisant
peut-être un peu plaisir et en oman en
rénovant des sites qui sont plus ou
moins comme on dit rabin et vous
utilisez valoriser des espaces du coup
les bus raconte une histoire aux gens
qui vivent ce qu'ils vivent les
territoires et derrière on pense aussi à
l'avenir grâce au futur dans des
préfigurations dans la prospection aussi
c'est un métier qui n'a pas vraiment
limité qui s'invente qui s'invente 116
est-ce que tu as ta race et avoir
finalement ce projet à poitiers la
normale le victoire reçoit nicolas ex
étudiant de l'école
il est à son compte depuis 18 mois il
confronte sa pratique au terrain et au
principe de réalité
le cette envie de faire en sorte que la
créativité
le projet artistique le beau etc puisse
se concrétiser par quelque chose de
viable qui va fonctionner dans le temps
que la personne va pouvoir s'approprier
entretenir ce avoir fabriqué de l'utopie
concrète la question du paysage je pense
qu'elle est lé pa technique à la base
parce qu'effectivement c'est énormément
de
d'histoire commune qu'on partage de
culture c'est beaucoup de choses qui
doivent s'apprendre se comprendre c'est
beaucoup de transformations qui
s'explique par les usages la question de
la transformation du paysage c'est aussi
les questions de transformation des gens
enfin de la façon dont on vit ensemble
et donc la transformation des
territoires